herzlich willkommen zum neuen video wir
sind wieder in unserem garten denn ich
bin wieder bei meiner familie
deswegen wird wieder in unsere
mysteriösen garten gedreht wo schon
klassiker wie nachbarskinder rasten aus
quarzit entstanden sind oder die einer
rettung oder die eier oder channel ist
schon viel klassik entstanden und ihr
seht ja mit diesem kleinen auf ok hier
haben wir einen tisch nach diesen fisch
seht ihr leere wasserflaschen mit
diversen über gesichter sozusagen
flaschen mit flaschen als pablo
märz und april hätten wie sie darüber
stehen zahlen und das hat das folgende
auf sich wir machen heute youtuber
zielschießen wir haben da hinten mit
startlinie
weder diese staatliche stellen wir
unseren schulen mit diesen ganz hier von
da hier drauf und youtube bringen
unterschiedlich viele punkte
die bringt 25 den übrigen 50 mehr
quartal bedingt 75 mio
bringt auf 75 und dahinter natürlich der
absolute klassiker der jackpot apo-med
ungefähr 100 punkte vom berühmten becker
war deswegen auch hier sind noch an den
schläger ende war es kleine dog leute
hätten sich zu ernst wenn euer lieblings
youtuber ist dann hat er jetzt fünf
sekunden zeit um abu raed oder david
bowie oder matt ist der beste die
konturen sohn in die kommentare
schreiben
dann abonnieren kann was er was er alles
machen wollte auf youtube schießen frank
youtuber erschossen
frank flaschen auf flaschen wir haben
werden den job verstanden hat es gelingt
den neuen job bitte alles navigieren
hier sind jetzt jeweils zwei schüsse
drin ich würde sagen jeder hat 33 x 4
in ihren vier wänden ort gibt's wieder
wie ganz viele kommentare aller halte
dies für eine gute idee sind die neuen
dieses kastanienblättern vorbereiter
egal weiß nicht ob ich ein bisschen
links darüber das könnte sein ist aber
wie die ersten schuss ein treffer
da hast du das für die baby getroffen
jetzt überlebt also über die dinger
nicht und ist keine punkte darunter
gehauen und schrift
den kollegen hier das denn ich würde
sagen die jetzt einfach weiter durch ich
mache noch meine restlichen acht schüsse
nachbarn finden dieses verhalten
verdächtig mit recht
die fresse oder nicht
nur ist knapp an der 2
und von zwölf schulen bringt damit
überhaupt nichts weil die dinge einfach
so krumm fliegen
leider nur 25
also ich würd einer schere auf den ab
ich würde auf den abo gehen aber der
abbau würde halt nicht auf die wir es
gehen
er hat den abo wer hat den akt alter bis
2002 gezielt das wäre okay jetzt hast du
noch einen einzigen muss die bibel pixel
wolfurter alter so viel wird hier
geschehen höchste verbrauch gegeben so
seit wert sein
alles klar damit hab ich 75 100 250
punkte geholt und dresden oder
genetische die bestimmten leicht
korrigiert nach unten er ist einfach in
der erde stecken geblieben spray mit den
dingen in vallendar einig was wer sagt
dir schon moment ihre halter wenn du
kannst waffen aber murmeltier in die
büsche oder ging mitten durch schläge
aber es ist los war das ist schon 62
länge wächst hast du noch 50 punkte
steigt
acht teile verschossen 50 hektisch
werden noch zwei schüsse damit habe ich
schon dran
okay okay was du machen kannst du hast
zwei schüsse blind über den rücken ok
weiß wie macht trick schock über den
rücken okay wenn du einen von den tricks
trifft das instant gewonnen aber du
musst dich auf die hier stellen oder
zusammenklappen und finde den rücken
oder über die schulter oder so so kurz
danach herlind und nach hinten schießen
und ein bisschen darüber
in diesem sinne ich hoffe auf den job
verstanden in diesem video
wenn er von eventuellen zweite folge
haben wollt vielleicht mit youtube die
ihr in diesem video den kommentaren
vorschlag dann schreibt uns auch in die
kommentare
wir wollten in diesem video
ich wollte in diesem video was isst du
gerade bist was auf jeden fall hatte ich
heute dem video mit an bord eine
bestrafung einzubauen
weil ich immer bestrafen geben wie es
auch langweilig und er in diesem sinne
lassen
maxis unten verlinkten der beschreibung
check in ab und bis zum nächsten mal